denn in echtzeit impuls kann hat er noch
viel gefährlicher als in der bearbeitung
denn den reichen also steht also der
busfahrer deckt sich jetzt neues und da
jeder interessent
lotte was geht so ich hab mal wieder
richtig großes vor und zwar zeige ich
euch dass musik von staatsgeld ganz ohne
effekte und hofft es einfach macht also
mir nicht böse ist dafür weil naja also
bei schaut einfach echt lächerlich aus
ohne ja jetzt kommt dann als die musiker
rausgehauen gerade eben erst und ich
durfte das tatsächlich auch film und
schneiden also auf jeden fall immens
laune gemacht also hat mich eingeladen
zu sich und dann haben wir zwei tage in
der schule gedreht zusammen mit seiner
crew also seinen freunden und ein paar
von euch also die leute die
zufälligerweise gerade in die schule
gegangen sind wie vor ich euch jetzt
aber das video ohne effekte zeige zeige
ich euch erstmal wie die ganze magie
denn eigentlich entstanden ist fangen
direkt mit dem schottern wo sich der
normale bus in den bettel bars
verwandelt weil einfach battle das thema
sogar dass wir normale busse dafür
müssen wir das einfach analoge battle
das abfilmen zu können hier habe ich
tatsächlich den blauen himmel als green
screen verwenden können um den bus
auszuschneiden hier sieht man jetzt
gerade das rohmaterial wo der battle was
vielleicht eingesetzt wird aber dafür
muss erst mal der alte verschwinden und
deswegen habe ich eine szene aufgenommen
wo man quasi die gleiche kamera
einstellungen sieht nur halt ohne alles
jetzt kann man auch schon im battle was
auf den echten bus drauf setzen weil der
selbst bestünden aber was natürlich noch
fehlt sind diese schilder die
eigentliche vor dem bus fahren müssen wo
es braucht jeder gute battle was
natürlich einen schatten und dann kann
er auch schon abwiegen da der übergang
jetzt auch nicht so spektakulär wir
natürlich noch so explosions sachen
drüber gemacht ein bisschen rauch nach
ein bisschen bewegungsunschärfe drauf
und dann war es auch schon mit dem
ersten schock ich habe übrigens auf dem
bild von dem dreh auf instagram gepostet
zusammen mit dem dann als kind der
sängerin des songs der aja also checkt
das auf jeden fall mal habt ihr seht
hier meinen namen eingeblendet und dann
kommen wir auch schon zum nächsten
schaut hier seht ihr jetzt schon in den
pools granaten short und dafür brauchen
wir natürlich erst mal eine geile impuls
granatenexplosion hier konnte ich jetzt
tatsächlich auch diesen orangen
hintergrund als green screen benutzen
das gleiche habe ich auch für die wurf
animation der impuls karate gemacht und
dann habe ich direkt aufs filmmaterial
gezogen und sohin animiert das ist
einfach zu der bewegung des werfen denn
passt und zur richtigen zeit auf dem
boden auch kommt jetzt im moment sieht
natürlich noch nicht so aus als würden
die wirklich weit weg explodiert
explodiert und es werden die wirklich
weit weggesprengt werden dafür muss sich
die beiden erst mal einzeln ausschneiden
und dann nach hinten animieren ihr seht
dass hier hier habe ich den lehrer im
blauen hemd ausgeschnitten nachdem der
lehrer im weißen haben jetzt auch aus
maskiert wurde wusste ich nur noch diese
explosions animation darüber legen und
ein bisschen bewegungsschärfe drauf
machen und berdych lässt fertig so
kommen wir zum letzten schritt bevor ich
euch das video ohne effekte zeigen
das ist der jump shot den habe ich erst
mal direkt in fordert auch nachgestellt
damit ich quasi die mir dass die ampel
so nehmen kann und diese
brauch folgend wege um dann war der
erste schritt ähnlich wie beim letzten
beispiel diesen jungen aus zu maskieren
und dann so zu animieren dass ich quasi
einfach ganz ganz hoch springt das dir
hier gerade aber das ist natürlich noch
gar nichts ohne das amt weil jetzt
springt aber nur wieso ein superheld in
die luft deswegen habe ich das stammt
hier ausgestellten haben coolen schatten
runden gemacht
sieht ganz gut aus erzählt allerdings
noch seine füße hinter dem tempel was
natürlich nicht sein sollte das habe ich
die auch nach außen das kehrt jetzt ist
es eigentlich schon fast fertig achter
fehlt noch dieses zeug was hat einfach
über ihm liegt also das ist ja wirklich
schon fertig ich wollte mir ganz gut
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen und jetzt
sehen wir uns endlich das muss ich
wieder von standards guelland ganz ohne
effekte hier immer schon den ersten
schritt der ohne bearbeitung nicht ganz
so cool aussieht und zwar mit einfach so
ein komisches chemie modell genommen ihr
seht dass hier das einfach so einen
molekülen modell von irgendeinem
fulleren sehr interessant ist ja
gebildet was ich dann getrackt habe und
da einfach diesen posten hat darauf
gesetzt denn wie oft diese jungen
natürlich nicht wirklich eine vorder
port auf den fußballplatz sondern
eigentlich überhaupt nichts also hat
wirklich nichts in der hand wer wirklich
schlau gewesen denkmal zu setzen aber
dann hat man dann auch entfernen müssen
aber ach doch kann der lama schott ist
auch so ein schrott der ohne bearbeitung
nicht ganz so witzig aussieht er
ziemlich komisch weil er klatscht
einfach so sagen haben auf diesem glück
und es passiert nichts und er gibt also
richtig war sinnvoll und naja jetzt
passiert aber gar nix also ich muss
sagen jetzt wirklich gut gemacht also da
ist es echt gut gegangen diese taktik
der einzusetzen ist auch ein cooler job
find ich aber ohne sie nicht ohne sind
aber du willst dich aus also der start
ist ohne arbeit und auch richtig gut
denn in echt ist dieser impuls kann hat
sie eigentlich noch viel gefährlicher
als in der bearbeitung
er fliegt einfach komplett auf dem
rücken und ich glaube man hört in der
aufnahme noch so wie ich sage perfekt
einfach weil sie allzu für für ihn
natürlich kacke ist aber für das video
ist natürlich cool wenn es möglichst
realistisch wirkt der clip hat und
effekte natürlich auch eine ganz andere
wirkung und zwar springt der junge dann
wollen
auf ein stolpern so ein bisschen für die
nachbearbeitung ist natürlich echt gut
also wäre es echt gut gemacht aber sie
natürlich trotzdem ein bisschen wird
sich aus wenn man die nachbearbeitung
nicht hat ich glaube das hätten die
wenigsten gedacht dass in diesem shop
auch visual effects drin sind denn es
spielt ja gar nicht vor ort sondern
einfach mario kade und das liegt einfach
daran weil wir kein vorderlauf der
switch hatten aber mit der
nachbearbeitung haben wir das zum glück
noch ein bisschen retten können bei
diesem sport haben und wirklich viele
gesagt hey lasst doch antwort diese
trenker so wie sie vorhin waren jetzt
wieder mal wie sie vor der bearbeitung
aus gesehen haben ich finde schon cool
aber ich finde einfach diesen vor analog
wie viel geiler ist auch einfach was
besonderes wenn er plötzlich sofort
einen getrennt sind deswegen wer auch
immer gesagt hat dass das ohne
nachbearbeitung besser aussieht war zwar
weniger aufwendig aber ich finde es hat
sich gelohnt
also den stolz bin ich ohne bearbeitung
richtig gut also mit auch aber ohne
jetzt was man auf was dann passiert also
er geht in diesem bus rein und
eigentlich war geplant dass daran mit
fährt und dann irgendwo danach steigt er
wieder zu uns kommt angefahren hätte
eigentlich kann ja der direkt aussteigen
nicht meinen also steht also drin hat
der busfahrer deckt sich jetzt nahe ist
und dann geht der workcentre und ich
sage ihnen auch noch er soll aus dem
bild rausgehen weil das für das video so
besser wäre da passten so wird
sicherlich wird sich zu sehen wir uns
alle ziemlich angestellt haben was
hierfür auch gut gewesen wäre diese
karte wirklich eins zu eins an die tafel
zu malen wer wirklich cool gewesen aber
wir haben es uns ein bisschen leichter
gemacht und einfach die eier
ausgeschnitten und quasi diese fahrkarte
runtergesetzt auch hier diese tracking
punkte die mir quasi geholfen haben
diese tafel bewegungen nachzuvollziehen
und dann darauf einfach diese frauen
abzusetzen bin ich echt ziemlich coolen
job eingehen wenn die dann einfach diese
form der karte was man halt auch bei dem
schock habe ich die gute ausgeschnitten
und die fahrkarte nach unten gesetzt und
die dadurch zur vorderen lehrerin
gemacht auch beim letzten start denken
sie jetzt wahrscheinlich hey wo ist denn
da visual effects er ist ja gar nix aber
jetzt guckt euch mal ohne an
da stehen nämlich zwei leute im
hintergrund natürlich ein bisschen
uncool dass wir das einmal vergessen
haben den zu sagen hey vielleicht ganz
cool da nicht zu stehen
ein stückweit arbeite aber ich fand den
schaut einfach cool deswegen dachte ich
okay dann müssen wir retten dann müssen
wir die leute einfach raus machen und
dank der wunder der technologie gegen
gesagt das war sie mit diesem video
zeigt genau dann freut man sich gefallen
hat und wenn ihr mich auf dieser reise
begleiten möchte dann abonniert mich
doch gerne denn morgen kommt direkt ein
video mit staatsgeld und dann wo ich
gegen die fortan spielten das müsst ihr
euch auf jeden fall angucken und ich
würde sagen dass wir uns morgen macht's
gut
[Musik]